dad I'm glad that you're here we need
you today please do a live Instagram
yeah we're library we're on the air and
on Instagram on get Alma's Instagram I
love the way you see my name is a
perfect
no he's GAD not good you said good this
is Jim Ed BOSU hello sure Jim gets
nervous in front of cameras it's not
like speaking French am I good oh I knew
what it could have fooled me with that
bull you're welcome dad thank you so
much for having me that's what they say
in every show yeah that's standard
opening hey man thanks for coming on
having me no more medians in America say
when they're looking for a joke onstage
it's good to be here a lot of crazy
stuffs going on that's that [ __ ]
comic going I don't know what to say
right now you want to talk about yes
what else you know it's funny man I was
just no it's not it's not come on yeah
it's not funny no oh that's what they
say no but hey man you know it's funny
it's just like one of those lines a guy
uses to get into a bit oh that's funny
you know does you does a lot of that Oh
rich boss
every time he's in here every time you
ask him a question he goes huh what's
that but you I heard you
yeah it's a technique we used to think
right I don't know Jerry Jerry Seinfeld
says says I'm quoting him like the Dalai
Lama now yeah it says don't ask don't
ask questions to people don't ask them
any questions there's no audience yeah
like don't do that makes you guys' you
guys use uber and then you start your
bid that's you know right why you just
do it right you're gonna do it anyway
regardless of what they say yeah they
say if they say no okay I'm not doing
the right cuz when I was new my buddy
Frank tailpiece I would always tell me I
asked too many questions because it'll
be non-stop [ __ ] its approval seeking
you want that affirmation from the
audience yeah and it's a weird nervous
thing and it just becomes a habit even
when it's no longer a nervous thing it
doesn't mean anything
yeah so do you guys like really who
gives a [ __ ] you but they do it no I do
do it I try not to do it as much but
there's yarn on the
have of your honor program to stop stop
doing it yeah it's pointless you're
working on it yeah what about comedians
who leaned on the brick wall like all
they're the buddies like on the on the
wall
I've noticed that Center is like it's a
Comedy Cellar and stuff like they'll put
their like hand on the wall or what like
there's there's just stuff that they
need to touch around sometimes when
you're nervous she'll do that because
you want to brace yourself against
something solid yeah by the time it's
just because it's comfortable really
yeah sometimes just standing there you
tell the difference like when you look
at a comic can you say like that guy's
nervous he's phrase gonna fall down he
needs to brace the thing it's a
connection to something like Colin will
do it but he's relaxed I'll put his foot
up so that it's just a comfortable way
and you don't get to do it in most shows
most times you're on stage you don't get
the [ __ ] press against the wall it's
just kind of like standing against the
wall and talking it's just comfortable
I think the mark of like a confident
comedian in 20 he he prowls the stage
like a panther ya know the confident
comedian is when he doesn't need anymore
to wake up in the morning and come to a
show like this like when you're become
you know right you don't need it but ROM
I need it I need you guys we need you
too my love I love coming here that's
what I would say 50% of them of myself
tonight today is I'm happy to be here
and 50% is we need to sell tickets for
those shows I see but I would like to
get to 80% of happiness and 20% of
tickets that's a 100 percent one day of
just I don't give a [ __ ] I don't want
I'm sold out I want to just come in and
hang out that's what I want to do right
for me it's 90 10 tickets whenever I
feel ready over here [ __ ] tickets
that's usually the range of tickets I
have sold so more more you could do this
for everything in life
like going to dinner with your wife or
your girlfriend and what's the
percentage like pleasure and I have to
do it because you know I got I have to
gain kind of mild mileage right I mean
it depends on the day right like if it's
a if it's a day where you got to sleep
in and you're well rested and you guys
are getting along you know might be nice
to go out and get some food like you
might you might have a good time
yeah but then there's like the Friday
nights you're exhausted from the week
the last thing you want to do is even
talk to anybody she wants to go out to
dinner and tell you about her you know
why isn't she tired of the of her week
to talk exactly she runs around nitinol
week we are very mean what's that mean
misogynist misogynistic just a little
phrase to protect myself from all the
people that I have you heard what he
said I hope the American radio I like
going out to dinner I love it but I know
it's just a very little social
interaction I do and I don't cook so I
like to go out and eat with people I
went I went out my ex lest everyone
looking at is the [ __ ] clock cuz I
have to get up in the morning oh my god
god dammit I gotta go home and pack and
you know it's a [ __ ] insult you know
what I did last night I took nyquil at 9
p.m. because I have to force if I if I
did I don't do drugs I don't drink a lot
I don't if I did drugs oh my god I would
be because I had to to force myself to
stay at home it was one night off and I
was like no I'm not going to the comedy
club I caught my good friend Ryan
Hamilton I was gonna meet him at the
other the Comedy Cellar
and I said no you come to my place and
we ordered food you know where we
ordered from my moons oh that's right
next to the Comedy Cellar
we were addicted and then I took the
nyquil at 9:30 I don't even know what
I'm telling this boring story but it's a
great story
it has falafel with Ryan Hamilton it
took night well yeah that's a series
that season one that season one because
season two I take something else right
we're neither comic I I take I take a
heroine with Jim Norton that season two
our analysis in nine oh yeah yeah yeah
season two is Tylenol PM with Robert
killer no yeah Rob luckily it's two and
you have to not something more like
softer a softer but Rob Robert Kelly is
like kind of you know severe it's not
severe but you know that's 110 cm 10 yes
yes
Mandy wasn't I dunno I took Thailand on
with the Keith Alba shot I don't know
now if that's a comedian yeah yeah you
know right community dad I don't want to
worry you
or put any undue pressure on you yeah
but but I want you to know the book
literally before you came in this is a
new system that we have come on
literally like minutes before you came
in this is tiny Anthony and he's one of
our producers merde loaf that's right
[ __ ] loaf they call him yeah okay he
comes up with like ideas for the show
and things we should be doing on the
show and you don't do them generally not
they're not the greatest ideas in the
world but his new idea that we wanted we
want to empower him so we want to do his
ideas and what he said was we should do
a segment called rate the guest and rate
the gun that's right know like okay and
what we do is we talk to a guest and we
do the segment and then like after you
leave we all get around when you're not
around anymore and we talk we give you a
letter grade on your appearance like a
shadow like you're in high school right
and I did it for the other guest this
week yes did pretty well yeah but wait
what's the idea of this I mean I okay I
feel like if he doesn't like you he can
just sit there this guy that you don't
know just sit there be like dad you know
what I love this show I loved this show
because there were there was no things
like that there was no such a like
organized whatever segment like and now
this is the thrown on the chopsticks
game right yeah I it was great you know
back in the day this show and now I
changed so much it's too regimented
regiments segment the money the
sponsoring and everything that you raise
the guests and then we don't need to do
this do we I want to rate you you know I
see more people who do bless you my
friend and God bless you
oh my god
that car crash guys let me just be on t
like I'm sorry I'm talking to my
Instagram father crime lab so people oh
please
what do they know Wow what did they say
no bacon France she wants to know your
name my name is Sam Roberts I'm the last
professional broadcaster he said some
Roberts are you married yes yes he's
married
what's his friend she's okay with that
oh yeah yeah is she into it yeah Sammy
just razandrich
no Samia Jim not on some Hulbert nouveau
project Erica Daisy they complete more
fairly be don't give up Suleiman if I
pass it right yeah what's that insulting
what you said you know just talk about
this stupid ideas yeah what are you
giving dad so far a blast energy he's
funny he gods do you think it's
insulting that somebody like that would
even have the audacity to sit there and
judge your appearance whatsoever like
isn't that a little like I think it's
[ __ ] are you
I think it's funny you do you know
what's funny these days with the we know
we've heard so many jokes about the uber
thing and raining the uber but the thing
that they do when you leave when you
leave when you get off the car they ask
you please would you put five stars for
me yeah like the ask you five stars you
cannot ask someone a rating the rating
is what I write think my honest
assessment of you without your
requesting it right yeah yeah I'll give
them five stars in a little tip it all
depends though excuse me a money bag i
if they if they do the right thing
I I do if they take the directions I use
ways I have my own app you drive I try
he gives them that's funny when Jim goes
into an uber he's like I have candies do
you want it says no is my temperature
okay yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna sing that
song music is good that's what he does
you know he's a he's a hospitable
it's Jim nor okay we're gonna say
bye-bye I don't want to hold this phone
and doing alive when I just put it down
I don't know that's gonna be too long
for them though [ __ ] him okay yeah
you could yeah but we're facing Troy's
crotch you could just like what I want
an angle where we see if you wanna rest
it on the table right Don Troy table
pointed towards us if it's the selfie
cam you just want to point to the you
because you figured you'd be popular
friends that French chicks not gonna
happen to me she wasn't into you see
what she looks like who cares
by the way Instagram live is pretty good
I've done it where you can actually just
bring people in to join you and Chad
thousand people we're watching oh my god
that's more than once more yeah today so
do you think I thought it was 700 no
7000 cool did you not get seven thousand
people watching yours to realize not in
a row so I wanna know something yeah
people are listening we're all over
America and the world really Canada US
Canada u.s. yes everyone where are you
promoting gigs oh la like you sell well
in Montreal I imagine you do very well
Montreal was the first city that was
sold out in a few days boom like in a
few days really I'm doing Sunday
Montreal and and I do two shows at the
oil Empire it's it's sold out how big is
that place it's uh 1200 okay I'm into
the song yeah 1200 yeah 200 yeah that's
good that's great Montreal is it
we met in Montreal for the first time
when we met not the first time you are
we met like very briefly you want to
have a branch it oh that's right and
this very nice hotel you were weird a
beautiful girl I didn't want to interfer
you no no no I remember saying I wanted
to talk to her but you were here so I
don't blame you you could have
cock-block me make more money how would
have a lot of he yeah yeah had you take
all those Jim was talking to her it
would have been a double [ __ ] block
short of yeah like all your logging yeah
[ __ ] blocking that's great right right
but what happened how she caught hard to
say
oh park mark Normand is here just gonna
cut block me now he is gonna [ __ ] bug
you he he wanted I didn't realize is
actually gonna come he said
I thought he was joking he said he was
gonna be from it come do the show for
five minutes so he got a ride to the
airport because he uses the car service
oh is that why I like this pose yeah I
like it
someone tries to imitate to impersonate
a friend's people they have this the
same thing that we we've never heard in
France actually they make it like you're
an arrogant type I don't know I remember
doing this
Marc Maron podcast and he wouldn't stop
like for like five minutes
oh come on that's it I know you don't
even hear that name in the sounds that
you hear being made over there it's like
you guys okay
Lacerta - do you say certitude certitude
sure went to servitude 30 to 40 dude
when you sure about something you have
like positive whatever okay let me give
you an exact search engine T yes
Americans really think right that Jerry
Lewis was his biggest fans territory was
France and he's much more popular and
friends and it's yes he was popular but
who said that friends really we loved
him but not more than the US I don't
understand this name it was true I heard
that my whole life the Jerry Lewis was
most popular in France yeah he probably
spread that rumor hmm I think I don't
like the rumor I spread about I'm being
there in France yeah yeah when I first
moved here right oh man that was great
to invent the whole story you told
everybody checked no I did arenas and
stuff nobody I've never seen him there
no mean he's never interested you told
everybody I'm really don't worry I'm
really famous in France I'll be famous
here what's gonna go uncheck they didn't
check because America guys don't care
about the other that's literally when
when rolling first booked you on the
show here's again he's really big in
France I'm like oh yeah I guess we
should take him on the show yeah it was
the king of baguette yeah let's bring
the king of forget to our table
that's right he's more of a forget but
the accent thing when I went to
Australia to do the festival there
everybody made fun of Americans by going
oh my god hello look at this like that
was our valley girl voice that was every
joke
that's funny cuz by the way first of all
you've never been to Australia we all
know that we know that come on let's not
lie it's not like he said no been trying
to sound like you were [ __ ] raised
there that was weldin he said now been
like a local in France when they want to
make like they don't want to imitate
Americans they do the same thing
especially like women oh my god yeah
yeah because they think every America is
like oh that's amazing but that's kind
of how American men also mesh fun of
American women yeah the enthusiasm of
Americans is really interesting in our
eyes you know like oh my god this is
great and this place is great even if
you don't know people you go hey how are
you like even if you say I'm getting
nice to meet you hey God what's up nice
to say it's totally fake yeah or when
you do a set in a club the guy he hasn't
even watched a such great job man okay
see you later because the honesty would
be too unpleasant I didn't watch you nor
do I care now right on a song it's not
that I don't like you but I haven't
watched because I have something to do
we're re between you guys that okay
let's be dishonest
everyone yes the last 30 seconds is
we're going on if I see the last 30
seconds a guy because I'm after him
great job I don't the first fourteen and
a half minutes rude bit I know we're all
so obsessed though with people thinking
that were nice people that's true like
you want it you want to be able ok I'm
just gonna take a mental note the GAD
zhan stage right now so I can say
something nice when he gets on people
want to look good what cuts what happens
with the celebrities everywhere they
don't want to be or do good doing a look
good right I have friends they fight for
dolphins earth feminism everything but
they're [ __ ] right in real life but
not bad to look good on Instagram it's
very important to fight and to save all
the Dolphins
well because on Instagram you're talking
to whatever 7,000 people were just
watching you live who cares if like if
ten people in your life know that you're
an [ __ ] but you've tricked a hundred
thousand into thinking you're a person
go for the numbers right that family
hates you that's it Alec Baldwin calls
his daughter a fat pig right but then he
goes on the news and goes I love Wales
right he said he's such a charming fun
guy right you know except if you're his
daughter we like when celebrities hate
each other there's something enjoyable
cuz their lives are so good mm-hmm you
see a celebrities life is so great it's
just that's what he was like watching
them fall apart because kind of fun to
watch them there's so much of a better
life floor I would like to see an actor
talking about shooting a movie and he
didn't like anything of this because
it's always oh yeah I read the script I
was like this is the script I've been
winning for you know all my life and
then this director is if there's just I
mean one director really understood who
I was it's him and my partner was the
bet I would like to hear another story
maybe not that II when it went like
catastrophe but just something real
something different cycle yo I showed up
and I was sure it's gonna be a like
really bad and I don't know sometimes if
you get the right actor and they're old
enough and the movie was long enough ago
oh yeah you can get a real Lance like
when we had you were here for John C
McKinley was him oh yeah and he was
talking about Sean Connery and what an
awful person he was like that was there
had been enough distance he's secured
his career Connors not gonna hurt him at
this point exactly Michael Madsen did
the same thing he goes over his movies
and he will rate which ones were sure
I mean he'll tell you why he did him
Michael Madsen also thought I was a liar
for saying I didn't hit my wife he said
the dog is right that Michael Madsen is
very perceptive it's a great I've got a
bright man yeah I got a lot of shiver
that McGinley [ __ ] joke as it was
that I thought you were just mad about
start now
John or the Internet did they you know
in a fun way
okay you know like that was crazy you're
a near lunatic that I need to say Carol
how do you say Palmilla do g'day that's
hard no sarcasm fifty shades of gray
no I'm more
and I know it's stupid but I don't know
I can't handle the the no sarcasm
sometimes on social media I put these
days I sometimes supposed to stupid
montage of pictures just for fun like me
doing a crazy dunk like jumping and I
have the Lakers Jersey whatever and some
people comment oh Photoshop I'm like
yeah yeah Photoshop being silly
being just what to do who do you think
you're fooling is well you can't you
have to that's a problem in social media
is you have to add an emoji so people
know that video being sorry there's no
vocal tone in social media can text like
get if you did like consider next time
you put the Photoshop up but in the in
the description you put a little smiley
face with the tongue sticking out so
people or awake wink yeah yeah I do that
when I'm talking about girl through text
on a wink I'll make you [ __ ] wink
cuz she knows you won't exactly is
goofing around that's all
yeah sarcasm does not translate in doubt
yeah they don't get irony or subtlety no
it really is but we're still moving more
towards texting to communicate than
talking I love it
did you perform last night yes sir we're
upstate where our two shows I did a show
in Pleasantville for about 40 people
then I did a bar show in Yorktown for
about 20 people you know how are they
the first show is amazing so you were in
the best Chester yes yeah with any mark
headline shows where they just kind of
spot I was headline the first one and I
was just like I show a guy put on he's
like I'll I'll fill the room said Lucy's
laugh lounge and then the other one was
somebody's like I see her like 15
minutes away tweeted at me come to my
show it's at a bar and I said oh sure
good now that was broth if I if I had
known that mark Normand was bombing in
Westchester I would have been there do
you like the special guest intro I
thought in
ladies and gentlemen this guy sometimes
we get drop-ins and they're like ooh
Jerri oh yeah I hate that especially can
you imagine with me like I feel I did
two shows no two gigs like sets in
Brooklyn for the first time one was at
the Eastvale you know yes great
the other one was great but for it was
really really interesting it was in the
work how you say a co-working place you
know in the day it's like co-working
working is yeah and it was great the
crowd but it was so weird because there
was the window and you could see through
the window at the comedian like you're
facing the crowd right and then your
back is in the window outside with the
so I distracting I couldn't do my set
without talking about it of course I
started just talking about how I feel
tonight like a prostitute in the red
light district in Amsterdam and I have
to do stuff so people so people can get
in what they do over there you know they
show now I said to the crowd please show
your laughing so people can and they
still show something like so it can
appeal and I did a whole thing about it
but it was really weird I don't know if
you ever did it work yeah this this bit
this think about the situation worked
really well but the material not as good
as I thought because you know I was
distracted but you know the the place so
the show was great and the people were
really amazing there could the audience
see the comics that weren't on stage
yeah hi in the comics that were on stage
yeah
so what net label the guy performing
like if somebody's a fan of yours and
there's some guy performing aren't they
gonna be looking behind the guy
performing to be like oh what's GAD
doing back there that seems really yeah
acting for lasting I'm on stage if
you're looking at five board comedians
behind me nobody wants to wait for the
guy to get through on today so we're
just going to sit there and sulk you
know it's funny there's a club in Paris
and they have a greenroom for comedians
and I don't like it I'm like we're not
supposed to stay in a room all together
before going on stage what's the point
you know camaraderie we tried I know I
know
I like if I want to talk to you and I
see you in a club I'll talk to you but I
don't I don't need to be like sitting
with all everyone and well you know what
the audience wants to believe the
audience wants to believe to that green
room
it's hilarious the laughs that are
happening in that group I wanted to come
this morning that you know we're good
guys married guys no I don't want my
comics being good guys
I like the deviant you like flaws yeah I
like a tell I like that he's sitting in
a room jerking off and drunk and
whatever comic though you're not a
typical alright the audience believe
yeah most of the audience I believe a
lot of the audience even like Jim's
audience wants to believe that you know
no no that's just an act I think I think
a lot they don't they just don't know
none of it's an act by the way he's not
one bit and they know that some of these
fans even if you do the kind of a prank
like Jim would be in Central Park with
that we hire actors and a woman like a
wife three kids the stroller and he
plays with the kids and people comes to
him and the hello and he's like no I'm
sorry it's family time now I want my
family I would love to see that this is
a social experiment to see me with three
kids strollers is a big black dildo
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that's the payoff that's yeah let's do
it
you're not you're not a family man GAD
that's not in I am but son yeah I have
two sons but no I don't
whenever I see a family mm-hmm I'm not
envious no no I love I'm very fam I love
seeing my sons and being together really
heroes or friends in France but um my
friends don't understand sometimes I
said I see a couple with the babies that
they they walk together I'm like oh I
don't want to be like them and
like why I don't know why maybe this is
mean what I say no but no you're allowed
to have your opinion
I fly every weekend it's just babies on
a plane and the MA poor mama chefs out
sorry everybody
that's brutal I never want to do that
you know it's amazing you think after
you have a kid you're gonna change your
opinion of other people's kids might
change it doesn't even see a kid on a
plane I'll look and go and then there's
our future you know you like that yeah
but the real problem of what he said
just now which one it's a real problem
is that you fly you fly commercial I'm
sorry you know it sucks and I'm in coach
baby I don't understand why yeah
probably financing I was teasing a
little bit this engine Chris D'Elia
these days because he sold out he sold
out he was on my show that I we shot in
in LA for Netflix through the series I
did one episode very funny about him
doing dick jokes and me don't understand
I just come from France and he has to
explain to me the whole structure of the
joke with the dick joke it was very
funny so we met and then whenever I see
him like he sold out Carnegie Hall he
did sold out Carnegie my last two women
- oh yes wait and then he goes wait in
line for hours take his shoes off flies
coast commercial I said [ __ ] like now I
talk like him [ __ ] what [ __ ] only [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] and wanna get up on a
private jet weather what is wrong you
made money yeah that's a lot of money
your whole profit margin yeah private
jet cars get 5000 what 30 what
cross-country 30 grand where from where
from LA no that's I don't do that that's
too far
that's too much more - how far do you
fire on a private jet sorry how far
would you fly on a private jet uh two
hours and how much is that gonna cost
more or less I'm not gonna tell you come
on I got an open up for a thousand no
because this is a program we do with the
charity and uh you think I 2010 it's
like five figures I'm not doing that
what's five figures but Boston in New
York could be uh oh just 12,000 New York
to Chicago three
thousand of light of Chicago that's bad
get the [ __ ] out of here not bad I
really go to [ __ ] pilot school and
[ __ ] work for the airline
you can try okay I know about planes
okay I love LA New York City Hawker 800
you can't do this do it straight we
display we got to refuel Jim doesn't
never does it straight no he does not
he's a hawker Oh waiting was I can get
now puns in and in in English he's gonna
cost 35 grand to fly to Miami
you fly to Miami for like 250 bucks I
know it's great I love elephone and you
can meet Chris Chris D'Elia on the plane
that's what you get but commercial but
you started do a little better you get
Economy Plus likes little leg little leg
room get on the plane first get that
overhead maybe a snack yeah yeah I mean
a little more pay more for first that's
slang with a bunch of losers I hate that
Bingham friends I fly private chef was
on mail de what does that mean elegant
way of say [ __ ] you that I never say
that Jews are male oh yeah it man it's
good at it that's gotta be some you're
still with me in Economy Plus you got
that right I mean I like it hey I'm I'm
gold I think it yeah
Oh what about this picture what what I
saw this picture everywhere is on a
scooter no Jerry is on a scooter with no
what is that it was that picture Jerry
Seinfeld on a scooter yeah I thought he
liked I loved the professionalism she
just repeated because we are the
audience you are great Jerry amazing
thank you I'm such a big fan
oh thank you I love my fans so really is
great look like you're a family man and
we love it I am
just a nice guys your birthday what sign
are you a star C star sign okay nobody's
gonna answer about Jerry's on a scooter
you could just text him and ask him no
you know Joey you know Jerry
billionaires yeah yeah what's he doing
there comedians and cars no it's the
scooter comedians on scooter yeah it's
like scooter he's getting arise zipping
around that's what I would do if I was
Jerry you look silly no I don't know I
want to know why he's on this good
anyway call and ask him so the caption
will tell you yeah but I don't see any
wink so maybe it's not funny he wants
right off right he he was a big
proponent of no marriage no kids for
years and then he shot left flipped one
day and really now he's like he's just
the family I know but he would always
never get me you know he was the the
manchild that was this whole thing the
big boy you know sneakers and funny ties
and whatever but sometimes you meet
somebody that you actually like you know
what I mean like I think people who have
you met his wife people who are like you
know I'll never get married are like
guys who have lifestyles that you know
are a certain way they enjoy them
killing it brilliant air doing good yeah
young ladies in the park right but don't
like any of these people right sometimes
you just meet a person you like I could
hang out with that person I don't know
you meet someone you just want to spend
time with after a while you like that
what are you yeah yeah also you're 52
yeah when you yelled it does matter I'm
50 I look at things differently than I
used to yeah I'm like yeah who cares if
I [ __ ] this one